la situation en afghanistan qui sera au
coeur d'une rencontre aujourd'hui entre
angela merkel et vladimir poutine la
chancelière allemande se rend à moscou
aujourd'hui on en parle avec notre
correspondante à moscou verhaeghe aux
fans
l'arrivée des talibans au pouvoir en
afghanistan a bousculé lors il est
l'ordre du jour de la rencontre entre
angela merkel et vladimir poutine la
question du gazoduc nord stream ii est
désormais passer au deuxième plan selon
le porte parole du gouvernement allemand
les deux dirigeants en dehors de la
situation en afghanistan vont évoquer
d'autres sujets internationaux majeurs
tels que l'ukraine et la biélorussie je
vous propose d'écouter des
chalets où je peux vous dire que
certainement seront d'évoquer les
grandes questions internationales qui
sont actuellement à l'ordre du jour
after
nature et c'est évidemment l'afghanistan
c'est bien sûr le conflit dans l'est de
l'ukraine pour le règlement duquel la
russie pourrait faire bien plus que ce
qu'elles faisaient frémir tout quand tu
as tout
bélarus
c'est la question de la biélorussie un
pays où un dictateur agi de la manière
la plus horrible par rapport à sa propre
population et à notre opinion les
dirigeants russes ont une influence sur
lui aussi je fus rome règlent au stade
le dernier tête-à-tête entre bladimir
poutine et angela merkel date de janvier
2020 la rencontre à l'époque avait
également eu lieu à moscou depuis les
deux leaders échanger régulièrement par
téléphone la dernière conversation
datant du 21 juillet le communiqué du
kremlin consacré à la rencontre
d'aujourd'hui a été extrêmement
lapidaire je propose d'écouter les
discussions porteront sur l'état de la
coopération bilatérale dans différents
domaines et ses perspectives de
développement
les parties examineront également un
certain nombre de questions
internationales et régionales
d'actualité impossible cependant
d'imaginer la rencontre au bowling
merkel sans discussion à propos du
gazoduc construit mme de qui malgré une
panoplie les sanctions américaines doit
être terminée si la fin août selon le
chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov les tentatives de saper le projet
vont tout de même continuer écoutez
[Musique]
je suis convaincu que toutes les
tentatives de le sachet de le contester
d'assortir son achèvement de conditions
quelconque sont vouées à l'échec
mais on verra des tentatives pareil
avocat me sur 12 heures
en outre la commission européenne se
comporte de manière pour ainsi dire
désobligeantes il ya quelques années
lorsqu'il ya eu des recours concernant
la légitimité de ce nord stream 2 quant
au fait de savoir à quel point elle
correspondait à la directive de l'ue
relative au gaz et à ce qu'on appelle le
troisième paquet énergie les juristes de
la commission européenne a
officiellement et en conformité avec les
prescriptions et les procédures
juridiques rendu leurs conclusions selon
laquelle north stream 2 n'était pas
soumis à cette nouvelle directive
relative au gaz parce qu'ils avaient été
négociés officialisé juridiquement et
financé bien avant que cette directive
est vu le jour zaugg d'ottawa kkk un
bloc messieurs accorde bien que l'europe
devait leur destinée
la dir hawtin avait déclaré lors du
forum économique de saint-pétersbourg en
joie que la pose de la première ligne du
gazoduc était désormais achevée il n'est
pas exclu que la conférence de presse
avec la chancelière allemande puissent
être une occasion d'annoncer la fin des
travaux pour nous